right before you sat down I just found
out Hart like a truck went platinum in
Canada how are you feeling I'm on cloud
nine it's it's crazy it's just you know
I've been at this a long time I've been
in Nashville pursuing music for 12 years
and was pursuing it way before then
um but I'm from a town of 200 people in
Northeast Louisiana and to think that we
went platinum over here in another
country it blows my mind so 12 years ago
what kept you going
um I guess I'm I'm just crazy enough to
keep going I'm telling you I feel like
any normal person probably would have
packed their bags and headed back I
lived in a little camper trailer for the
first three years I was in Nashville and
um should have packed that thing up and
and headed back to the house but I've
always had this weird sense of Peace
about knowing that this was it you know
I mean I was nine years old when my
parents drove me through Nashville on
the way home to Louisiana and I remember
that certain feeling I remember exactly
where I was on the interstate in the
back seat I was looking at the Batman
building on I-40 and I told my family I
said this is home
goodness you know you do hear artists
who knew at a young age this was you
know this is their dream and not just a
dream but like you knew this is going to
be your reality I know it did your
family always support you always yeah
you know I feel like that's kind of been
the case it's it's where people kind of
see something of me before I see it in
myself whether it's my mom and daddy who
would help me sign up for Honky Tonk
Talent searches and Country Colgate
showdowns like you name it they did
whatever they could to to see me do what
I love to do and and that's the case now
with my with my team in Nashville and
with so many different people in my life
and now you're the most nominated female
artist at the ACM Awards this year come
on female artists of the year I believe
that that's true it's huge it really is
okay how'd you react to all that oh my
gosh
um it's crazy really how far we have
come even in a year when I think about
where we were even with ticket sales and
things like that and it just seems like
things are finally coming to fruition it
seems like a lot of just incredible
blessings every single day and all I've
ever wanted to do is write music that
people are connecting to and latching on
to and moments like being most nominated
for the acms is is proof that if you
keep your head down and your blinders on
and you don't worry about what everybody
else is doing around you that your
dreams can come true it's so funny it's
a tough lesson not comparing what
everyone else is doing and just stick in
with your your own path that's a tough
thing it is it's really hard and you
know there's a lot of opinions about
what you should be but I'd like to keep
my circle small and the kind of people
who love me for me and wouldn't want to
see me change maybe of course you know
they want me to be better and do better
um but the the folks that love you for
you yeah uh your tour is called country
with a flare yeah I love that I mean the
style alone I understand you got some
Flair going on is that a good way to
describe you as a person yes me as a
person
um my my style but also my music bell
bottom country means country with a
flare it's about finding whatever it is
that makes you you and different and
leaning into it as as much as you
possibly can and being 190 percent
yourself I like that 190 yourself 90 I
like this okay it's my new Modern Life
for the rest of this year uh bell bottom
country is so successful when you put
out a collection of music that people
are really connecting with do you feel
pressure then to put out you know
another album or another collection
where you're like okay it's got to be as
good as this for sure I always I want
people to feel that growth with me
whether it's
vocally my songwriting I want us to feel
like we're kind of taking that step
together and I feel like every record
kind of it it symbolizes that moment in
my life
um so of course I want it to get better
and better yeah I want to write 300 plus
songs to be able to choose 11 or 12 that
go on the record
um I guess I'm a little bit of a
overachiever well that's why you're here
today
uh you're having fun on Tick Tock
there's like this whole Trend okay
that's I love your reaction when you
first started seeing that as a trend
what was your reaction I'm like first of
all okay so if y'all don't know what
we're talking about you explain it my
big old butt went viral on Tick Tock and
everybody's like I gotta don't like a
truck
um but so much love for the booty so
much love for the booty yeah I was like
I mean my booty introduced my music to a
lot of folks and I'm okay with that I
think what would Dolly Parton do oh she
would own it and then continue to do it
that's right and so that's what I'm
gonna do I'm like you know I've been at
this a long time and if you found out
about my music and you stuck around
because of the butt or because of the
music you're welcome I love that what
would Dolly Parton do do you ask
yourself that a lot I do I do I feel
like a lot of artists do yeah she's
she's the best when I think about just
an incredible um career and I think
about somebody who has uh stayed true to
themselves it's her I mean and she's
just incredible at everything that she
does I mean
business woman singer songwriter you
name it Dolly Parton's got it going on
yeah well you have a going on too let's
talk about actress Yellowstone not
everybody gets a role written for them
on one of the most popular shows out
there today how did that change things
for you I really think it helped put a
face to an aim yeah
um you know I think some folks knew my
music from the radio
but that is really what connected the
dots and I'm very lucky to have had that
opportunity I mean I've never acted a
day in my life this was yeah I wouldn't
have known that yeah this is my first go
at it I mean in middle school and high
school I impersonated Hannah Montana and
that was a little dose of acting I guess
you could say yeah definitely but um but
this was it diving head first into one
of the the biggest shows in the world
and I got to share my music I got to
play a musician on the show so I'm sure
everyone's asking you obviously we all
love this show but we're hearing it
might end after season five what do you
think's gonna happen
you know what I've realized I've
realized that the TV business is even
crazier than the music business that's
good to know
um so I'm waiting for them to tell me
too I'm just as confused as y'all are
y'all holla let me know we need answers
uh well I'm sure JLo and Ben Affleck
would also like answers because it's
come out that they're massive
Yellowstone fans which means they've
seen you I know that made me feel weird
that maybe I was like okay because I
don't know I just I love JLo too and I'm
like that's pretty cool that JLo like
she probably wouldn't know me from Adam
on the street but it's cool that she
watched me on the show she would know oh
no she knows you she's like oh season
two like yeah yeah she knows yeah that's
amazing
um when you're on tour what is one thing
you cannot live without
oh my goodness um well here lately it's
been my dog what kind of dog do you have
I have a little French Bulldog her name
is hippie and that's like just French
Bulldog her name is Georgie let me see
okay thank you to be friends white oh I
love white friend shoes she is oh wait
it's a girl yeah okay they've got to
meet oh my gosh
bring
there's something about French Bulldogs
I love them I know what does your French
Bulldog do for you why is that important
to have her on tour with you it's like
taking a piece of home yeah with me I
mean she really is just like that
security and yeah she brightens
everybody's mood out on the road I mean
sometimes we're out for a really long
time and um it's nice having a dog
around is she protective over you heck
no she would she would let somebody get
me and not even think twice about it
she'd be like well she gone
okay listen I need a little bit of
hippie then with uh with Georgia because
George is really weirdly protected
really yes I hope he needs some lessons
I know okay a playdate is gonna happen
uh listen I'm so excited for you so much
is going on how would you describe life
right now
um a whirlwind I'm trying to keep my
feet planted on the ground yeah you know
and
and it's just it's crazy
um that I've known I was going to do
this I've known that I was going to be
here I didn't know it was going to look
like this or feel like this and the
truth is it's a lot different than I
thought it was going to feel and look
but better
um what this is a lot better it really
is and if this if this would have
happened to me 10 years ago when I
wanted it to I would not have been ready
so I'm grateful for the time that I have
spent just
hours an hour what do they say 10 000
hours makes you a professional what you
do I probably got me about 50 in there
so I don't know what that calls me but
um it's feeling good I feel very
thankful so how exciting is it for you
to be able to tour around Canada oh my
gosh it's wild yeah it's been a long
time coming and um we're we've got some
shows coming up with Luke Combs who was
a dear friend of mine we met back in
2014. he used to come over to my camper
trailer where I lived and we'd write
music together and it's just crazy to
see I mean he is literally selling out
a few nights of stadiums like it's
really insane and he has exactly who he
is as who he was and it's it's really
crazy and it's rare when you find people
who are just as kind as they are
talented and that's Luke Combs so and we
have our own headline and shows we're
going to be out west doing a whole lot
it's exciting to be here